hello everyone this is samuel l.jackson
and he plays Nick Fury
that's lisanna what's your laughing
Lynch in it yeah well the new Doyle Rhea
Rambo that's Jemma Chan out there she
plays Minerva and this is the wonderful
Bree Larson who plays Carol Danvers aka
Captain Marvel superhero would you
rather you rather or rather would you
rather have a human sized body with a
hulk-sized head or a hulk-sized body
with the human eye fixed and that's a
couple of movies guys I already have
that human sized body with a hug son I'm
gonna go that too because you can still
be sharp yeah so be sharp on the body
this is what I'm saying you put a lot of
hair so you just cover up the rest of
your vibes back notice you still put
lashes and makeup on Oh would you rather
fight for the last piece of pizza
against Minerva or a fleur c'n I don't
really understand the flirting or what
it can do for what I saw the movie that
fits like kind of intense and whack so
I'd probably rather fight you I'd be up
for the challenge of the flocking really
yeah you had more time with the flirt
can I just you'd have a better chance of
surviving with the torpor interesting
yeah never just it never is not merciful
would you rather have immunity to toxins
and poisons like cow hunters or have an
unlimited supply of vibranium I'm just
learning that I have I need to talk
Carol Danvers doesn't get a hangover or
you can have a lot of vibranium it's
tough it's very tough when you do I'm
about immunity yeah I mean am I gonna do
with memory honestly
yoshino protect myself for the rest of
my life
ah honestly all I was thinking about is
no hangover still I'm still musing going
pretty good I'd rather be healthy you're
in a band forever be healthy
secure the bag would you rather only be
able to listen to star-lords 80 playlist
for the rest of your life or only be
able to watch 90 movies from
blockbusters on a VCR I'm kind of down
with the block what survive yeah I'm a
real movie person plus you know there's
music in movies exactly the only thing
we're talking about here is rewinding
guys would you rather have everyone know
you're a superhero or live a secret
double life so much more stressful and
way more awesome I'm going to be I've
already done that double we're all like
we want to be Hannah Montana witty
rather has no keys ring blades for hands
or Thor's hammer for legs
hammer for legs you can throw some
flares on and make it work which way the
hammer topical it do we get to decide
which way the hammer go a hammer four
legs I mean well the hammer four legs
means that you could like get places
[Applause]
there's no knitting there's no needle
pointing there's no thumb war
there's no lots of stuff there's no lots
of things so maybe hammer legs would you
rather shape-shift into the Hulk every
time you sneeze or shape-shift into
goose there's a cat I'd go with goose
because like what have we been talking
about 82% on this press for the cat so
it's just like oh I'm feeling a little
insecure I guess I'll just turn into the
cat that everybody loves you know
nobody's gonna run away from me when you
shaped it into goose the big grand dude
is like really nice I'm here it's really
nice you rather go on a road trip across
the universe with the Avengers are the
Star Force well as a member of Star
Force I have to
overseas tastes awful I mean I'm a
member of Star Wars that I don't feel a
certain allegiance part is that I was
like okay I mean not to be rude know the
Avengers do parties Arius they eat in
interesting places and you know chilled
and you know they laughing we do that
Neverending left in that stop boy it's
true but a notoriously dry sort of
serious if we're talking about the real
people
I'd love to I'd love to go on a road
trip a few I'm just saying see that I
still wouldn't go with the adventures
[Music]